I hope he walks in with my water so you
could edit it out I don't
welcome to mastering the middlegame
today I'm going to show games that were
played in 1987 and 1988 because do Danny
Machuca is birth being happening around
then okay and they're all pretty short
but not as short as the amount of time
it takes my comer to bring me some blue
water here we go
good timing all right wait another
hidden I can't find them yeah okay
Tsun Tsun coming is Mike my new novel
drink like a Grand Master okay so this
game was played in 87 against a former
Michigan chess president Gary kits also
an expert and it was played in the
masters experts championship ooh
now in all three games that we're going
to look at today
my opponents made strategical mistakes
followed by tactical mistakes tactical
mistakes are my favorite as long as I'm
not the one making them okay so the
first game was a grünfeld
which very popular right now fact I had
a grin fouled in round two of the
tournament that I played in last weekend
normally I show you lovely people at
home the games from the last tournament
nah I'm just kidding you're not lovely
and but all my games were end games
right away it was move ten move 11 and
the Queen's were traded that way I
blunder my Queen less often so I had to
go back 28 years so I could find a
suitable game for this super intelligent
audience right Danny okay so when my
opponents play the grünfeld
I play all kinds of stuff a few days ago
we had the tournament I played H for
very suspicious okay
and normally I play e3 which is also
suspicious but this game I played more
normally I played the Russian variation
okay sounds good right
and and usually I reserve that for a
blitz tournament when I'm Russian but
here I use it anyway
so what move can white play to invoke
the Russian variation anyone and you
want you at home
now often nobody yeah you can do it I'll
give you a hint it's a Queen move I'll
give you another hint it's White's move
Queen to b3 that's right yeah now I have
pressure on this pawn so they usually
take and white makes a lot of Queen
moves which usually isn't good but in
this particular instance we get this
formidable center because we're getting
rid of this pawn here on on d5 now
there's a player you've all heard of
well not all of you but most of you and
he had black in this position against a
world champion the only time they ever
met and that was the game Bob Vinick
Fischer exactly right and Bob gonna go
Lee played Fischer once and this was the
variation that they played and my
opponent played a six which is very
popular right now although it wasn't
what what Fischer played and black wants
to play b5 and kick the Queen again okay
so I played a five I was aggressive
first and my opponent moved his Knight
to g7 actually this move looks sort of
strange because it blocks the bishop on
ca but it's very normal in this
variation because the knight often goes
to b6 hitting the Queen again Knight d5
would be what we'd want to play but
since it loses a knight it's not very
good white just takes it okay so I
played Bishop e3 defending my center my
opponent attacked my queen but I saw it
and I played queen c5 now it's hard for
blacks to play c5 which they normally
play in the grünfeld and if my opponent
attacks my Queen again then he's
blocking his Bishop on CA it so he
played nine see
developing a piece and not blocking his
bishop and I played rook to d1 and I've
said this in many lectures but none of
you were listening I always like when my
rook and my opponent's Queen are lined
up occasionally I get to play rook takes
Queen sometimes it happens okay Bishop
to g4 pinning my knight and Bishop to e2
unpinning my knight and ready to castle
this is a typical grünfeld tight
position White has a nice Center black
has all his pieces out and a lot of
people are afraid to play this variation
with white because White's making a lot
of Queen moves but I sort of liked it
I'm blocking my opponent's Bishop and I
have my center pawns sort of up in his
grill okay and he played h5 I don't want
to call it the losing move that would be
for a more advanced class but h5 is a
terrible move because you're weakening
your King and you're not getting
anything out of it now especially on the
Kings side that's right now a
grandmaster acquaintance of mine
actually from around this time yeah
about a year later so he hadn't told me
yet so that's why I didn't know he said
Ben never moved pawns okay because when
you move upon you can't move it
backwards although I didn't really take
his advice with these pawns
although I did take his advice with
these pawns so that's a good percentage
and the problem with h5 is the pawn
can't go back to h7 or h6 except with
lots of cheating and because you can't
go back you've given away a square that
square is g5 now my bishop can go to g5
my knight can go to g5 and you can't
harass me with age six so that's not a
good move h5 weakens the King weakens
all the squares okay and I played h3 I'm
hoping to get to two bishops my opponent
retreated so I can't get the two bishops
and I immediately play Knight g5 so 19:5
has several purposes I want to play g4
baby when is Bishop I want to play f4
and solidify my center and I want my
knight
to be able to go to the e4 square and
the Knights really good on g5 it attacks
a lot of squares in his position and he
played Queen to d7 and I played f4 the
reason I played out for is I want to
play d5
what's wrong with d5 something wrong
with it
yes well said
d5 looks good
well the truth hurts I can't argue with
that
dad no matter what it was I couldn't
argue with it so okay d5 attacking the
knight but there's something wrong with
it
does anybody know what's wrong what's
wrong with it unprotect something what
does it unprotect you with the right
answer what the Queen all right so
Knight takes e5 and I would lose a pawn
and then I would certainly lose to this
guy all right
so I protect my pawn with F 4 and now I
can play d5 which I did he played a rook
g8 and I play d5 now that's the center
I'll take a sip of water so you guys
could take a picture of that position
yeah you two at home
take a picture isn't that beautiful
Center okay so my opponent saved just
night and now I played four tricks this
game was played many years ago when I
was a kid and tricks are for kids
I played g4 and after g4 probably in a
super grandmaster event black would
resign but this was a super Grand Master
man this was the Masters experts in East
Detroit which no longer exists they
changed the name of the city I can't I
can't make that stuff up it's now called
East Point that's one word instead of
two okay now this is the g4 is a tactic
many of you are familiar with but you
haven't had a chance to
accomplished yet and that is why
laughter the trade the best move is
actually Bishop c2 and then after rook
c1 or rig d2 I guess she should resign
but he played Bishop takes pawn and now
we do an interference tactic okay I
would like to take the bishop for free
but unfortunately as Queen's defending
it if only we could do something about
that I think I should do this lecture in
French close enough
yeah but he's so close he gets credit
okay f5 is close but it's actually II 6
because II six attacks the Queen and
attacks the bishop okay and for those of
you who have played white or black in
the Albin counter gambit which is not
many of you we see this theme happen in
this opening also East sixth with
interference
now again resigning is reasonable
because you're going to lose a bishop
and get checkmated instead my opponent
made it worse within resigning
he took pawn tanks and after Bishop
takes now a referee came up and actually
stopped the fight I couldn't believe it
my opponent was quite woozy at this
point okay because down easily not only
is he down at peace but I have a lot of
threats okay but his Knights well-suited
to take care of it
yeah so in that game which ended now my
opponent gave me the center I was able
to advance all of my pawns and then he
mistakenly thought his Bishop was safe
on f5 but it wasn't because all of my
pawns were surrounding his Bishop and I
made an interference movie six after
which it's completely over without the
move g4 and e6 whites should
strategically be winning
it's way too hard for this class okay
extra piece now this class does what I'm
talking about
you might not win but you know what I'm
talking about right then you went home
keep taking a nap okay so you'll get it
eventually
okay so that was my game with Garry kits
and then it all disappeared well that
was hard to understand okay now this
game was played the same year in the
u.s. junior championship in 1987 1987
Bronxville that was 86 I'm not sure
where wasn't 87 late a bit in Bronxville
okay
this is against Berta's ooh mikawa now
you'll notice one thing if I'm playing
in the US Junior Championship that means
my opponent probably doesn't play chess
anymore
okay I'm from the generation of chess
players who quit chests except for me
okay and the only one who plays
occasionally is Alex Fishbein it's also
Grandmaster but players like Patrick
wolf ins two arrayed shows Ilya Gurevich
who won the US Championship and the
world junior championship they work in
finance so either they're somewhere this
suburban home make it money or they're
in jail where they belong I'm not sure I
just saw the big short so I assume
they're all in jail okay well and trust
me I drew them as juniors and they
belong to jail then too
now I I haven't seen Patrick in a long
time but occasionally the Chess Club
here has big events like the Ziegfeld
cup and and Patrick came out to watch
the sync feel comforted one Shandor
dinner and he looks the exact same it's
been 20 years but he doesn't change okay
and somehow not in jail even though he
recently ran a hedge fund so you would
assume okay so this is my game with Bert
now unlike Mike comer who doesn't know
what the Queens gambit declined is I do
guess that's a good thing I was at the
last lecture where he called the Queens
gambit declined the Queens gambit
accepted he was close he was only one
word off okay now this we sort of
transpose and okay what happened was in
the cupboard lecture white Chuck so he
thought that was accepted
okay but actually black taking is
accepted okay I think white taking is
accepted with an e alright and I play
the boring variation because that's what
I do
and my next game is also in this line
and there was a game played in the
Karpov because smart off match around
this time probably 85 or 86 and Karpov
played Queen to detail and nobody ever
plays Queen to d2 so I started playing
it and Queen d2 has a couple of ideas
one idea is to Castle queenside and then
checkmate your opponent which I did the
next game the other idea is to stop your
opponent from playing c5 by playing
rugby 1 and making the d5 font a little
bit weak this pawn can be a little
tender so in one game I did one of those
and the other game I did the other and
now you get to see them both okay my
opponent took on c4 so now my comer is
is right it's the Queens gambit accepted
okay and I took back and taking on c4 is
usually not a good idea unless White's
already moved his bishop and he has to
take back and lose another tempo and
when you play the Queens gambit declined
or accepted that's a good thing to know
you don't want to take on c4 and so
White's already moved as a bishop so I
get to go there in one go and he played
Knight d7 it's going to play either c5
or a five and I play Riggs e1 dissuading
him from playing either so for example
if he plays a five and I take and he
takes it looks like I'm winning material
but probably I'm not because if I take
this
he could play Queen takes Queen check
and then take tonight and if I take his
queen he could psyche on f3 was check
first and then take my queen so he could
still play e5 well it's pretty risky and
my opponent did play e5 and I remember
yeah in this position a couple of times
I've played Bishop takes f7 check okay
somebody get
Machuca a handkerchief he's slow he's
foaming at the mouth
he's like Bishop f7 check I've waited my
whole life to play this move okay and
the reason you play it is if King takes
f7 takes and you try to do this now
Knight takes Knight is check when the
King was on g8 Knight takes Knight was
in check and black played Queen takes
Queen check now Queen takes Queen is
double check which is not allowed in
this position and after it takes then
white is up upon is that right yeah and
rook takes is even worse because now the
Queen on g8 isn't defended so you can't
play Knight takes because black loses
all of his pieces and if you move your
bishop away then I have a fork so
actually in the games where I played
Bishop takes f7 and takes my opponent's
just retreated and then white has
compensation for a piece I think I
played a six check and then it's a safe
King but it's not too safe okay not the
safest okay and I won those games though
they were very suspicious okay this can
I played more positionally I played d5
okay and the idea is I don't want this
pawn to go away
I want that pawn to stay there forever
that way his Knight can't go here and
his Bishop is blockaded okay Lisa
Simpson would approve okay my opponent
played rook e8 which I think just loses
a tempo and now I play Knight e4 one of
the reasons in chess it's very rare to
see me have this pawn structure with my
pawns on e4 and d5 which looks good is
because I like my pieces to go to e4
maybe my queen maybe my bishop maybe by
Knight hopefully not my king but you
know it's solid okay it's not like 95 is
made okay so I like to block eight on e4
if I put my pawn on e4 my pawn on e3
isn't controlling these dark squares
that my opponent might put a piece there
eventually
okay so 94 and he played a6 why did he
play a
six stopping Bishop b5 and preparing to
play b5 attacking my bishop and feein
Catalina's Bishop okay now if I remember
this game and it was only 28 years ago
29 years ago so I remember it pretty
well I think I was pretty proud of this
move okay assuming it's Bishop b3 okay
what do you know I still remember the
move I made a long time ago because now
my opponent plays Knight b6 to get his
Bishop out or plays B fight against
Bishop out this way I don't lose the
tempo my bishops safer on b3 because
it's protected and if I want to
checkmate him on the diagonal give me a
few moves I don't want my bishop on d3
because it blocks my Queen and rook I'd
rather have it on c2 then I can play
queen d3 and checkmate them so that this
was better on b3 that on c4 my opponent
played Knight b6 not attacking my bishop
so I can play d6 rar
okay now my bishops opened up that's why
I don't think rookie it was a good move
and my pieces are all really nicely
placed he played pawn takes letting my
knight come in and Rookie 7 and I
castled finally finally you want me to
knock castle might be right something
take the plot this pawn this one this
one yeah I was right let that joke
worked out well I could take the pawn
but then he would take all my pieces he
would play Queen takes check or he
wouldn't that he would take my knight
that he would take my bishop and then
he's got two bishops for a ruck very
suspicious okay and my knight on d6 is
so good I don't want to trade it for
anything
so I castled and he played Bishop g4
pinning my knight and I played Queen b4
and my Queen looks like it's doing all
this stuff but it's actually doing this
stuff attacking his bishop on g4
okay and I expected he would take my
night and then he has to watch out for
discovered attacks okay fact every night
move was a discovered attack and I
didn't really mind having the G file
open because I could put my rook on the
G file and I could attack his king my
king is actually pretty safe so he
surprised me he played Bishop to d7 so
he saved his bishop but he also stopped
me from doing this discovered attack on
his queen that wasn't nice of him okay
but his faeces are all terrible the
bishop on f6 really can't move this rook
can't move he just put the bishop here
to stop all these tricks and where's
this night going to go c8 boo so his
pieces are all terrible now I have a
knight on d6 and a bishop on the long
diagonal and my queen is pretty
threatening I played 94 of course I
could take a pawn
I could play four tricks but I like the
move 94 because I wanted to take this
bishop and then once he takes back I'll
check meet him which is actually what
happened so everything I wanted happened
and this position is so good for Wyatt
it reminds me of a saying from
Grandmaster Roman ginger Hashmi Lee the
only thing harder than beating him at
chess is spelling his name and Roman one
set of such positions I'm looking but I
can't find a move that doesn't win okay
so he'd really like White's position
here Knight 6b7 is good 94 is good
Knight f5 is good h3 is probably good
okay so I play 94 and he played a5
attacking my queen like I'm nobody
and we played an intermezzo Knight takes
f6 did he take my queen oh wait this
isn't the one o'clock kids class
nevermind right so he took and now
you'll notice my Queens attacked and
this is my chapter on the psychology of
chess if your opponent has a queen and
you did not attack it and they moved it
you might be worried because they move
their queen for no reason maybe that
queen is doing something when you attack
your opponent's queen
and they move it your leg well of course
they moved it I attacked it so now
you're not so worried about their queen
why well the guy who does queen I
attacked it however it could be the
place that I moved it to threatens
everything which was the case here and I
played Queen e4 and most people are
looking at this free pawn over here but
if you've seen the game where I lectured
on the win and against Doug Eckhart and
that was a lot of lectures let me tell
you then I have a much much more
important better threat and even though
my opponent was rated over 2,200 he
missed this tactical idea which costs
him the game of course I could also take
a free pawn and win the game so he was
less worried about that and instead of
stopping my threat he made it even
stronger very nice of him he played a
for attacking my bishop okay that
doesn't really prevent what I want to do
you'll notice my bishop and his King are
lined up on the diagonal okay because of
that White has a very strong threat
Danny
Queen g6 is correct so he should move
his king somewhere so that he's not in
this in this pin but instead he played a
four thinking my bishop would move I
must admit Bishop C choose a fine move
but queen g6 is even stronger since you
suggested it and now not only is he in
Shak and both of his pawns are hanging
and pawn takes is illegal the computer
won't let me do it because of this pin
and now you're going to lose all your
pawns would check and get checkmated if
I had an engine which I'm sure I do but
I the way I could ever find it they
would say something like +10 even though
the material is equal it really likes
white because white has a mating attack
for example let's look at some funny
variations that's the best variation
because now black already has three
pieces set up for the next game now me
what am I going to do how am i got the
pieces up my queens on h8 I can't even
reach it that's the one bad thing about
dgt boards I'm trying to set my pieces
up and move my King really far away and
now I can't set it up anymore okay
and if
goes back to g8 okay then I can do it
again
Queen g6 and I could play something like
Queen f6 also threatening me and now
you're down to pawns and I'm threatening
mate 9595 etc okay it would be checkmate
soon so here my opponent resigned and
now you know why he quit chess f5 that
would be better than losing everything
yeah after f5 I don't know I could take
the pawn and lose my queen that's
interesting or I could play Queen h4 h4
is probably safer although losing my
queen is tempting yeah I don't even
think I lose my queen I probably could
just go here and went upon although I
like my Queen over here because I got
Queen h6
I got Queen f6 I got Queen h5 and I got
this pin going on here f5 definitely the
best move yeah a4 that's the worst I'm
assuming my opponent's intention was I
would go here and then you apply f5 he
was one move too late yeah these things
happen but yeah f5 makes a lot of sense
still losing for him but makes a lot
more sense because his king is too
exposed
okay now the other one is much more
brutal okay and oh this is even the game
I was thinking of this is this is even
better
yes sir I changed my mind okay so this
was also played in 88 this was not a
Queen's Gambit although I had a Queen's
Gambit game prepared and then I deleted
it okay and instead I show a Carol con
Carroll cons always have good middle
games okay and actually this was at a
world chess festival where all the
leading players were there and we even
had some celebrities for example this
was played in st. John New Brunswick
which is in what country Canada and one
of Canada's
- actors is William Shatner of course
and when I showed him my this game he
was at the tournament I showed of this
position and he said Khan okay
me about half of that was lies but
someone was true the shandur part was
alive but the Khan part was true
okay so I played the Carroll Khan which
I play occasionally now now this time I
was playing the Colombian master Fabiola
Roda he is no longer a Colombian master
he's an American master and he lives in
Florida but this was a 1988 okay and he
played the advanced variation and
nowadays I sort of flip-flop about
whether to play c5 or Bishop f5 all the
world's leading players play which one
of those moves somebody yelled out very
quietly Bishop f5 so I played that and
now my opponent confused me which isn't
tough you played h4 putting it in H ok
and grandma Esther's today still argue
about whether to play h6 or h5 but to me
there's no argument at all h5 and now my
opponent decided to win my H pawn he
played 92 then 93 then Bishop e2 then
take my pawn so he's going to waste for
Tempe taking my H blonde I'll play take
his H pawn later so so you can do that
ISA --xe
Bishop e2 and when they attack on the
flank
you have to counter-attack in the center
so I played c5 c3 Knight c6 Bishop e3
and now this is a typical move in this
position but you guys don't have the
title to make it luckily I'm a
grandmaster though then I had no title
and I want to play Knight f5 right
because that's a good square for the
knight Knight f6 not as good because
he'll take it so most of you would
maneuver your Knight to f5 but I went
there in one move and actually the
arbiter allowed it hey here's an arbiter
right you've got me play Knight f5 see
ya okay III hope Andrew doesn't know the
rules
okay so I just played Knight f5 and one
move is that what I did not kidding
because I wasn't a grandmaster then I
was a fede a master so I played 9h six
like the rest of you okay I did it later
I forgot the game because it was 30
years ago okay I traded and played Queen
b6 it's coming and now my opponent made
what I would call the losing move
although I'm not good enough to say that
in 88 I want to take his be pawn and my
opponent wanted to trade Queens in this
opening white wants to checkmate black
because White has a lot more space
especially on the Kings side and Black's
not really ready to Castle kingside
maybe Queen side okay once the Queen's
are off black attacks d4 mercilessly
okay and then there's no counter play
for white so black wins
so Knight h6 to f5 and white of course
traded Queens activating my ruck very
nice of him okay that's why he later
went to the US he could play me some
more okay and I see three Knight f5
everybody trades and these end games are
always very favorable to black now some
of you have a different favorite
lecturer than me maybe you had brain
damage as a child okay I know at least
one person this room has and oh my cover
is not here never mind and those people
like yes or Sarah one they said wow what
a great lecturer and if the answer was
here he would really really really like
black the reason is yessir for a lot of
his career plied the French defense and
he always suffered in these positions
with his bishop on CA so this is a super
French defense because the bishop isn't
locked behind the pawns and in the
French defense and Carol Kahn one of the
things you're worried about with the
black pieces is getting checkmated and
here I'm not worried about that the end
games are almost always favorable to
black and this there's this is the same
because this pawn can be attacked and if
he takes this pawn that would be very
nice for me because I have a pawn
defending it so with the D pawn week
with my a file
open with my bishop being beautiful with
my other bishop being gray and I can't
get checkmated this is a very good
position for black in fact in a strange
coincidence I had a meeting attack who
would have thunk it not me okay he
played King d2 in the end game a lot of
people don't castle they want their King
walking up the board but I would call
this a middle game the main reason being
the name of the class is mastering the
middle game if this class was enhance
your end game then this would be an end
game but yeah that's the middle game we
should checkmate our opponent
I played King g7 and Bishop to b4 and he
played Bishop d3 trading pieces and I
took okay now we're going to vote
because voting is fun you can vote for
King takes c3 or B take c3 if you vote
for another move we have a one o'clock
class on Sunday that you would enjoy
you'd really enjoy it okay because you'd
be one of the better players and you can
email and and YouTube comment your vote
for this move very suspicious all right
who votes for King takes c3 one two and
a half four and a half and who votes for
pawn takes five five ok pawn takes is a
slight slightly better more people my
opponent played uh King takes yeah but
his Kings nice and safe until I made it
him all right the problem with pawn
takes is that when we trade bishops this
is what we call a good night versus a
bad Bishop my Knights on c4 forever even
thirty years after the game ends my
knight still goes to c4 on this computer
that's when you know the Knights pretty
good and as a pawn is weak I can double
rooks on the hay file and White is
struggling for a draw which he would not
achieve against the player of mine well
actually back then
okay but he took with the king better
for his pawn structure now my knight
can't sit on c4 because he has b3 now as
the young gentleman and the audience
pointed out check meeting the king is a
good idea if you're taking notes at home
write that down okay and I played rook
c8 threatening all kinds of discoveries
okay and my opponent prevented every
discovery by pinning my knight
now all Knight moves our double check I
would be checking him and he would be
checking me this was before Barney was
even a cartoon let's not a cartoon
anyone now
Bueller okay could I still move my
knight move your king up yeah if you
can't take my King as it would weaken
his pawn structure
yeah pawn takes King terrible okay so I
could move my King out of the pin but
instead I said get your Bishop out of
the way and if as Bishop gets out of the
way then I can make my knight discovered
checks okay if he takes my knight check
then I can infiltrate on c2 or c4
depending on where his King goes okay
for example this would give black the
advantage opposite colored bishops
always a draw
except here and every other position
okay so my opponent played the obvious
move maintaining the pin on my knight
so he played pawn a for right now my
Knights pinned and I can never move it
so we agreed to a draw thank you for
coming to my lecture
oh wait that's not what happened what
happened was I got medieval on him and
that was before was it before after Pulp
Fiction 88 I checked that all right what
do you think what's called fiction 94
yeah so even before pulp fiction I got
medieval here okay and you'll notice if
my knight could move it has a lot of
good moves but my knight can move Danny
Machuca foaming at the mouth
waiting to sacrifice the whole class
plays Rigsby five and now I have a lot
of night moves and this was 1988
so Night Moves was out right my son
actually went to the same high school as
Bob Seger but 40 years later okay true
story if you want to know where Main
Street is the one in the song it's in
Arbor not the other 5,000 main streets
in the US go left to the right okay
how's that oh this way
even your right stage right or your
right alright so in this position I made
a move so good even day Machuca will
like it
yeah I knew you'd like it
Knight takes d4 check we can vote again
you take with the bishop oh wait this
isn't the one o'clock Sunday class
nevermind okay
for some reason that class isn't
recorded darn okay
then you'd see some illegal moves all
right why not you because this is better
yeah 1995 is good for Black Knight d4 is
very good for black now we play the
ditions chest because White's pieces
disappear okay he could of course walk
into me also good okay but he decided
not to
he could play kings of b4 and then I
would play Knight check and then I would
have a very difficult decision about
which piece to take probably my flag
would fall or I could play for me
because
King would be sort of suspicious but I
want to take the king yeah okay so he
played King 2d2 then I played Knight b3
check now if this King goes to the back
row and back row wasn't good in 88 now
that's pretty complicated joke for you
guys you know big French Grandmaster
back row okay Adia was he alive maybe
might not have been now he was alive
okay if you go to the back row I'll take
your rook for free because this rook is
defending this rook notice all of my
pieces are active so you can sacrifice
material when you're taking everything
back and you've calculated that your
opponent is while King is terrible okay
so he played what move no I just said
how he didn't go back because he'd lose
his rock he wants to keep his rooks
protecting each other he's seven correct
that's that's that's the distant
opposition now King E - yeah a mirror
image of my king okay now most of you
would take the rook and you would win
because it's also winning but what's
that castles Castle c7 this one yeah I
know rook C - correct
now if the King goes to the back rank
once again the rook isn't defended so
even though he was Columbian he
retreated like a Frenchman Bishop - D -
okay I took and he played King e1 now
King e1 is excellent if he resigns those
pieces are already set up all of them or
in he's prepared to castle either way
now okay yeah unfortunately the one
o'clock class believe me now again I
could take his rook but my rook would
then be attacked so I played rook to be
- now I'm going to take your rock and
you can go to this safe square or you
can go down down the file here
you go down the file I'm going to play
rugby one check and win this rook
so probably don't do that so he played
rook to d1 and his rook is trapped on d1
very suspicious also I don't know you
got to see if your other rook
yes isn't good okay and as they say on
The Sopranos there's good and there's
not good that that's not good for him
okay that's good for me though mmm yeah
don't you sing soprano yeah now very
suspicious okay when he tells the truth
it's crazier than my jokes the next move
is white resigned that's good yes yeah
white gave up and then this game he was
crushed so badly they kicked him out of
the Columbia and he landed in Florida so
we could vote on that too but that's
tough okay that's 5050 okay I would pick
Columbia Missouri okay unless I was
remember his name for the joke who's
that guy who said miss miss world wrong
mr. numerous yeah he also had the wrong
Columbia yeah he spelled Columbia like
the Missouri one so maybe he meant that
though that well yeah but that was too
hard to spell correctly okay so in fact
I have a plan which I've worked it's
works to perfection that involves Steve
Harvey if the wrong person
also known as Donald Trump when is the
election we're going to have the
election results read by Steve Harvey
then it looks like we're okay alright
and again as ji welder like to say class
is dismissed